We're gonna get into the headlines,
but basically I just want to turn the show over
to someone who is basically one of my heroes,
writer, actress, singer, dancer, comedian.
Emmy winner.
Emmy winner!
She just won the Emmy for her amazing show
and she also,
as another one of her multi-faceted gigs is now considered
the greatest red carpet correspondent of our times,
check out this viral moment from the Met Gala
and it really did go viral,
now everybody does it on TikTok
so here's the origin story.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I know it ain't,
I know it ain't the stallion,
I know who I think it is.
You know it's your girl!
(crowd clapping)
Please welcome,
the one, the only Keke Palmer!
(crowd clapping)
(crowd cheering)
Yes!
I know!
I can swear I've been obsessed with you,
and I have to come dress as you,
go friend!
You're literally the best.
Oh my God,
you look so amazing.
I have just been following you.
I mean,
it's just Ross and I have been so excited
Ross is amazing as well.
Oh thank you.
To do this with you.
You have a new collection of essay's,
called Southern Belle Insults on Amazon.
Yes!
Tell us all about that.
Yeah, Lady Miss Jacqueline
is one of the characters
that I came up with on my page with Max
and we literally just did it as like a little sketch,
you know what I mean?
Similar to what you see watching SNL,
people do these different sketches.
I started doing that on my page
with lady Miss Jacqueline,
and I always had a dream of like,
what is her world?
Let's open up lady Miss Jacqueline's world
and why is she always be associated
to this character, Janet?
You always just hear Janet in the back,
"Oh, Oh, Oh!"
(Drew laughs)
It's almost like I want to be able
to get into that world
and then the opportunity came up with Amazon
and they're short stories
and they say,
"Hey, would you like to write five stories,
short series of this character",
and I'm like, "let's do it"
and that's when we created
the world of lady Miss Jacqueline,
which ultimately tells us about
the character that she always
is talking about in the sketches.
I'm very excited about people reading it.
(crowd cheering)
(crowd clapping)
All right, well, let's get right into it.
We've got the first headline and you know what?
It's Drew Barrymore,
look at this!
You guys, you have to see,
tearing up the CFDA's
Oh yeah, I see.
Drew when out on the town!
(crowd cheering)
(crowd clapping)
I'm sorry, but we've have to talk about this moment!
This dress!
I wish I could have talked to Keke,
I saw Zana last night and Nischelle!
Nischelle Turner was there?
Yes,
it was just fun,
I don't go out very often
Yeah.
I rarely leave the house.
I love that.
Please sit on my couch and eat takeout food.
(Keke laughs)
Do my homework and I'm with my kids,
it was really fun to step out
and wear Christian Siriano
Ooh!
And just have that fantasy moment
'cause it's majoritively,
sweat pants and take out.
I understand
but that was a movie star moment,
look at the twirl when I woke up on Instagram,
It's nice.
I was like the twirl!
It's the body for me too,
that body is snatched.
Yes!
The moments momma's
(crowd clapping)
It was a fun fantasy,
have you ever considered dressing down
the first time you meet someone?
I love this story because my girlfriends get on my case
so much if I go out on the rare blue moon of a date,
all they talk to me about is,
what are you gonna wear?
And it's not coming from that like,
"Ooh, let's get dressed in juju up"
(Keke laughs)
They're worried that I'm gonna wear what
I normally wear in my daily life.
The Wall Street Journal reports
that the newest trend in dating
is people are showing up in a first date
in sweatpants and little to no makeup.
Absolutely, absolutely.
I am with you Keke.
yeah, yeah, yeah
no for sure.
Some say,
it's low-key, feels more authentic,
quick way to weed people out who don't love you.
Oh my God.
When you go out of state.
Okay, why do you love this
and can you talk to my girlfriends,
who are literally like the sweats have got to stop?
Because the idea is that if unless you wearing makeup,
then it means you didn't try
but it's like, "I did try",
I brush my teeth, I wash my face.
I put on some clean deodorant,
I smell good, I put some perfume on,
but maybe I don't want to be dressed up, tightened,
Why do I need to pretend to be somebody else?
If I'm tryna get you to date me
and I'm telling you I've had great success
when I've just kinda been chill about it.
Honestly, my mom encouraged me
'cause I was talking to her when I went on a first date
a couple of months ago and I said,
"what do you think, mom,
I don't really feel like doing my makeup
I'm tryna' let my skin breathe,
should I put my contacts in?".
She said,
"no, you like your glasses,
wear your glasses you ain't got to do too much,
you want to put no makeup on, do it,
let him see you for who you are".
Best date I had.
Mmm-hmm.
Best date I had and I felt more at ease.
(crowd clapping)
(crowd cheering)
I felt more at ease.
All right,
next we've got to pick from the little yellow book
and that's our list of stuff that we love,
it's my personal curation
and I love to share it with people
and it's up on our website,
we refresh it every week
and today my pick is actually from Flower,
it's our brand and it's Blue Light glasses.
Yes!
(crowd cheering)
Blue light glasses
as we're all scrolling and typing
and looking at our screens, which we all are,
we're gonna give a pair away
to everyone in the audience,
Ooh!
Yes!
(crowd clapping)
(crowd cheering)
I wanted to share these with you,
I hope you wear them with all
the love that they were made for you with.
Keke I was wondering if you would actually curate
and do the entire little yellow book next week.
Yeah!
At like an all Keke!
Oh my god,
Are you in?
Absolutely!
Next week Keke Palmer's little yellow book,
taking over!
(upbeat music)